what's up everybody zacky here from geek
culture with another fantastic unboxing
of
world of warcraft shadowlands collectors
edition
so for my feather geeks who
have been playing world of warcraft this
is an epic edition of the collector's
set
so there are a few things in this box
that will uncover
as well as a few in-game bonuses
specific to this collector's edition so
let's
go ahead and start unboxing it
so the first thing you want to see is
the packaging it's a nice
kind of a chameleon
iridescent
um
color to it it's very nice
and it's just like a tome
or book
you'd see
in the games
so
if you just flip it open
it comes out
with
a nice
book
and the world of warcraft symbol
[Music]
in the book itself it's plastic
and it should have the key concept art
in it
that aside
this is what the book looks like
and what we're gonna do we're gonna take
out the wrapper and see what's inside of
this
so here we have this lovely world of
warcraft shadow dance
art book
place it here you can see
there are some key
counter parts
of world of warcraft shadowlands
so we've got some key concept parts
of the game
including
characters
locations
it's a really thick book as well
it's very nice
wow
yeah
very cool
so that's the art of world of warcraft
shadowlands
next up we have a world of warcraft
shadowlands mousemat
very nice
very smooth
what it looks like a world of warcraft
shadow lens
oh hidden under this
letter cover
is the world of warcraft shadowlands 3d
mobile code
and when you open it up it features some
in-game content that you will receive
with the epic edition
which is a shadow lens level character
boost
and
enema wermling pet
and saucelled overwhelm mount
vestment of the eternal traveler
eternal traveler's effect for your
hearthstone
and illusion and the illusion of rave
chill weapon and chant
of course you also get an extended stay
in azeroth
of 30 days of game time
very cool
on top of that you also get the world of
walker shadowlands soundtrack
which
features
16 different tracks and orchestrations
so if you guys enjoy the soundtrack of
world of warcraft
you would
be very happy to listen to all these
tracks yeah
and of course some promotional materials
of some of the blizzard games that you
get to play for free
such as world of warcraft
you can play free to level 20.
starcraft 2 is already free to play
heroes of the storm
as well as of stone
so yeah do check the other games out as
well
[Music]
and finally we have
four very distinct yet different
lapel pins
for the four covenants in shadowlands so
if you guys have no idea what it is i'm
on the same boat with you guys
uh can't wait to play the game
and
yeah
this is
from what it looks like this is
kirian kirian covenant or bastian
so what we have is kirian
necrolord
knight fei
and venthus
ventier okay
so what we have is kirin necro lord
knight fae and van thier
hope that pronounced it right
yeah
so that's it for the world of warcraft
shadowlands unboxing just to recap
things we've got the
world of warcraft shadowlands shattered
sky mouse mat
4 lappo pins
the art
of world of warcraft shadowlands
as well as
of course in the center
it holds the epic edition of the game
key of world of warcraft shadowlands as
well as the soundtrack of the game
and a very nice
box to keep all of these collectors
items together
so we hope you enjoyed this video if you
liked it give us a thumbs up do give us
a comment down below
if you can't wait to play world of
warcraft shadowlands
and if you haven't already do consider
subscribing
and smash that notification bell icon so
you can stay updated to our latest
unboxings geeky reviews and tidbits
until then
this is zeki
signing off wahoo
[Music]
you